so in the last 24 hours we have seen
these allegations made
uh coming out of michael schmidt's
forthcoming book
that when donald trump was rushed to
walter reed
medical center in 2019 it was not that
he decided to get ahead on his 2020
physical
we suspected that from day one because
it didn't make any sense
but michael schmidt is saying that
something medical was taking place
and that it was serious enough that mike
pence was told
in case trump has to be put under
anesthesia be on standby be ready to
take the helm
uh as as temporary president of the
united states
so donald trump raised without
uh uh prompting that he didn't really
have a stroke
on that day now that was weird because
it hasn't been alleged that trump had a
stroke on that day but let's put the
trump piece aside and focus on mike
pence now
mike pence was interviewed yesterday on
fox news by brett bayer
brett bayer to his credit asks the
simple and straightforward question
is it true that you were put on standby
in case donald trump had to be put under
anesthesia that day
the answer does not inspire confidence
take a look at what mike pence had to
say another candidate
from another party this refers to
michael schmidt's book where he says the
president went to walter reed which in
fact happened in november of last year
he says in the book that you were put on
alert to take
control to take office essentially if he
went
under for anesthesia is that true um
president donald trump is in excellent
health
and uh brett i'm always informed of the
president's movements
and whether it was on that day or any
other day
i'm informed but there was no there was
nothing out of the ordinary
about that moment or or that day and i
just refer any other questions to the
white house physician but as far as
being on standby
so the question is were you put on alert
in case trump needed to be put under
general anesthesia
and mike pence doesn't say no mike pence
says trump is in excellent health
i'm always informed as to where trump is
and what trump is doing
and nothing out of the ordinary took
place and go talk to the white house
doctor about how healthy donald trump is
not an answer that inspires confidence
in fact when i hear mike pence say
anything but no
what i'm hearing is yes but bret bayer
tries
again take a look at what happened as
far as being on standby
i i don't i don't recall being told to
be on standby
i i was informed that the president had
a doctor's appointment
and uh uh i don't want to say i must say
but i just want to yeah i i got i got to
tell you and
part of this job is you're always on
standby as your vice president of the
united states
um but uh the american people can be
confident
that um this president is in remarkable
good health
and uh uh every single day i see that
energy and high relief
i want to talk about i don't recall
being told
to be on standby says mike pence
if you know how politicians lie and
avoid answering questions
this is mike pence making it a semantic
linguistic argument
he doesn't recall being told
and the word used was not stand by
that's what mike pence wants us to
believe and then he goes back to this
refrain
of trump is in great health these are
not denials my friends
if i had to sum up what mike pence is
saying if i run what mike pence is
saying
through a politician uh
decoding device mike pence is saying
yeah that's what happened and i don't
want to talk about it
no sane person could realistically watch
that answer and think that mike pence is
answering
truthfully if someone is asked a yes or
no question
and they talk and they talk and they
talk without answering the question
then the most likely answer is the one
that would be most embarrassing which
in this case would be yes it is true
we lied trump didn't go to walter reed
for a physical
trump was abruptly rushed to the
hospital there was the possibility
general anesthesia would be needed
and i was briefed to be on alert for
that
he starts the answer with the biggest
lie think back to that he is asked
about whether this took place and he
says the president
is in great health we know that's not
true
donald trump is obese he's medicated for
high cholesterol and he eats a terrible
diet of fast food
and doesn't exercise so it starts with a
completely
obvious lie and gets worse from there
so we should continue to be careful
not to make specific assertions about
what happened
when these are not the allegations that
anybody with insight is making
so when trump denies that he had a
stroke we shouldn't say
oh he definitely had a stroke but it
should raise our suspicion because it
hasn't been alleged
trump is the one raising the idea of a
stroke
and that's what's the biggest red flag
here let me know what you think
i'm on twitter at deepakman what do you
make of donald trump's tweet
denying he had a stroke which had not
been alleged and mike pence
refusing to answer the simple question
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter
at deepakman